[Applause]
[Music]
today we are going to talk about the
most violent country in the world el
salvador when we think of el salvador we
think of salvadoran gangs
migrant caravans and the highest
homicide rates in the world
and this is just the tip of the iceberg
to give you an idea el salvador's
homicide rate is comparable to that of
countries that are
at war
[Music]
in 2015 the homicide rate in this
country was one homicide per 1 000
people to put that in perspective more
people are murdered in el salvador than
die in road accidents we are talking
about the land of the mars and what are
the mars well they are ultra violent
street gangs they're usually dedicated
to drug trafficking the members are
distinguished from each other by the
tattoos that typically cover
their entire bodies
the two most important gangs are the
mara salvatrucha and the mara barrio 18.
to give you an idea of the magnitude of
the problem it's estimated
that barrier 18 has between 50 000 and
000 members and we're not just talking
about violence a third of salvadorans
live on less than five dollars and fifty
cents a day remittances sent by
immigrants account for almost 20
of the country's entire gdp in other
words we're talking about one of the
most dismal countries to live in
in the world
however what have i told you that all of
this is changing yes indeed from time to
time characters capable of changing the
course of history appear and this video
is about to introduce you to one such
protagonist the new latin american rock
star we are talking about
naeb buchelli the president of el
salvador
[Music]
if you're watching this video in europe
buchelli's name probably won't ring any
bells but believe me in latin america he
is the new
messiah and the truth is that he is a
unique character within just two years
of his presidency he has managed to
reduce crime by
[Applause]
half
even the coronavirus has managed to
lower his popularity levels he is a
revolutionary
but not the classic leftist
revolutionary buchelli is one of the
youngest leaders in latin america he is
39 years old and continuously active on
social media and he's not afraid to make
drastic decisions to give you an idea he
just announced that bitcoin will be a
legal tender in el salvador so brace
yourself el salvador for a bunch of
people from reddit coming to visit
however despite all his achievements the
united states does not trust him check
this out u.s senators ask biden to put
pressure on president buchelli voice of
america
so what is wrong with neb buckelli i'm
sure many of you are already imagining
it it's not the first time that latin
america has fallen for a new messiah who
promises miracles and ends up becoming a
tyrant and the truth is
there are many indications that buchelli
could turn el salvador
into a dictatorship so the questions we
are asking today are what is pikeley
up to in el salvador are we talking
about the hero this country really needs
or is it just another aspiring tyrant
today
we will answer all of these questions
but first before we get started i want
to remind you that we have a newsletter
dedicated exclusively to the geopolitics
of latin america and talking about
latin politics
for only five dollars a month you will
receive three newsletters every week
where we will explain the geopolitics of
latin america in other words for the
cost of a big mac meal deal in colombia
you can get an
in-depth knowledge of facts that do not
typically appear in conventional media
stories that get lost in the noise of
everyday life such as for example the
real influence of china on the continent
trade conflicts between argentina and
uruguay are oil and guyana
all this in the style of visualpolitik
in collaboration with the consulting
firm perch perspectives so
don't wait any longer go visit
latinpolitek.com to subscribe and for
now let's get back to el salvador and
take a little look at some history
[Music]
a star is born the first question you
might be asking yourself is
where does the name name buchelli come
from i mean naive sounds more like an
arab name right well you are correct
buchelli's family
comes from palestine this may seem like
a side note but it is yet another symbol
of how far removed this man is from
conventional politics you will rarely
see him in a certain time but his
differences go far beyond
image and genealogy to fully understand
this figure we have to know a little
about the history of el salvador
[Music]
you see back in 1979 the salvadoran army
carried out a coup d'etat and
established a military junta in the
country this is how a civil war broke
out between the leftist gorillas the
so-called farabundo marty
national liberation front or the fmln
and the military this war did not end
until 1992 and left more than 75 000
dead in its wake in 1992 the two sides
went from confronting each other on the
streets to confronting each other at the
ballot box
but in reality nothing much really
changed violence in the streets and
corruption in government offices by 2015
el salvador broke its own record
homicide rate and neither of the two
major parties seemed willing to do
anything to change it however on the 3rd
of october 2018
things did change forever in respect
buchelli's story is a curious one he
began his political career in the fmln
that is in the left-wing party and
that's how he won the mayor's office in
san salvador however in 2017 he was
kicked out of the party under normal
circumstances that would have been the
end of his career
this is the 21st century and these days
politicians have a tool that few know
how to use well
social media
the internet allows us to have our own
means of communication without depending
on third parties some politicians like
donald trump and alexey navalny have
understood this
well but without a doubt neil buchelli
has managed to turn digital
communication into an
art form thanks to social media buchelli
did not lose contact with his voters and
that was how he announced his campaign
and his new party in 2018.
nuevas the new ideas movement and you're
probably thinking
seriously is it really that easy to set
up a political party overnight if any of
you watching this video have experience
in politics you already know that
setting up a political party
is pretty complicated one charismatic
candidate is not enough you need to
organize the base of affiliates plan
campaigns
et cetera so how did neil buchelli
create his party well in a masterful way
by opting for one that already existed
that's right who kelly joined a minority
right-wing party ghana the strategy
worked perfectly buckely breaks el
salvador's two-party hold on power ass
koa that's right rickely won by absolute
majority that is despite coming from a
minority party he won more than 50
of the votes and that's how he left the
other two parties in a corner and all
this
only 37 years old so what was his first
political act well
seconds before taking the oath of office
before saying a single word he took out
his cell phone and took a selfie to post
on twitter
you may ask but what was his electoral
vision what did bruckelli promise to
salvadorans to make them fall in love
with him in this way well it's very
simple um
[Music]
it may seem like a very simple slogan
but it was something totally new in el
salvador's politics to give you an idea
of the last four presidents this country
has had
three have been involved in million
dollar corruption scandals so the
hashtag
return the loot but in spanish i'm not
gonna attempt that sounded like music to
the ears
and we're not just talking about
domestic politics in september of 2019
brucella gave his first official speech
at the united nations and what do you
think he did well before he uttered a
single word when he was already up at
the lectern he took a selfie and
uploaded it to instagram to give you an
idea
kelly has 3 million followers on twitter
and 2 million on instagram these may
seem like usual numbers her political
reader but
remember that the population of el
salvador is only 6.4 million people
that's the equivalent of almost half of
the country following him
on social media as you can see we're
talking about a political rock star but
the most important thing about prukeley
is not his personality but his actions
this is where the least attractive part
of his mandate comes in we're going to
take a look at that
now
[Music]
a firm hand beyond corruption and
poverty el salvador's main problem is
violence we could say that the
salvadoran marriage are a parallel state
they live
beyond the law and there are hardly any
police who dare to stand up
you could say the salvadoran cities are
a war zone where the gangs have taken
over large territories under their
control so
under the hashtag hashtag territorial
control plan rickely deployed 2
500 officers and 3 000 soldiers to the
country's capital the objective was to
recover 12 territories controlled by the
mars from day one to the next the police
conducted controls of weapons drugs and
tattoos
[Music]
think about it gang members are easily
recognizable because they have symbolic
tattoos
for example members of the mara
savarutra are tattooed with an m and an
s in gothic letters the police arrested
thousands of criminals so far everything
sounds pretty good so where did the
controversy come from well the
controversy arises in the way they go
about it for example the police did not
limit themselves to arresting the
offenders but also took them to public
squares
to publicly shame them
[Music]
and you're probably thinking now so is
the iron fist approach working at least
well at the moment
it kind of seems to be to give you an
idea the homicide rate in 2015 was 101
per 100 000 inhabitants in 2018 it was
51 and in 2019 it was down to 36. at the
moment el salvador is experiencing the
lowest levels of violence since the end
of the civil war that being said el
salvador is still an extremely dangerous
country and the same goes for
corruption
[Music]
three months after berkeley being sworn
in el salvador launched the
international commission against
impunity the so-called
c-i-c-i-e-s cities i guess
in this way conflicts of interest would
be avoided
[Music]
in fact we have to recognize that naya
brukeli has been able to attract
multi-million dollar donations thanks to
a style of politics for example the
warren buffett foundation donated 25
million dollars to the salvadoran police
under normal circumstances almost all of
this money would have gone into the
pockets of some politician in this case
however that 25 million paid for el
salvador's first forensic investigation
center for the first time in the history
of this country the police will be able
to do dna tests in order to solve crimes
and at this point you might be wondering
so how does he manage the coronavirus
well
in this respect we would also have to
give berkeley a round of applause
[Music]
el salvador was one of the first
countries to act in march of 2020 when
there was only a few cases in the
country el salvador quarantined itself
to give you an idea at the time of
making this video el salvador has had 14
of the population vaccinated not a
spectacular number compared to the
united states
but remember that we are talking about
one of the poorest countries in latin
america
el salvador is much further ahead than
other south american countries like
argentina panama or colombia and all of
this explains why bruckelli's popularity
is unstoppable and whopping 88 of
salvadorans are very satisfied with his
administration
but his popularity is not limited to el
salvador and international politics
bruckelli has managed to achieve the
impossible his first trip as president
was to washington dc
there he met with trump's national
security advisor and openly criticized
china this happened in march 2019
months later in december 2019 he met
with xi jinping in china
from that trip he secured multi-million
dollar investment china is going to
build a sports stadium a library a water
treatment plan
and a vacation resort in other words
buchelli is getting investment from
everywhere china the united states japan
and of course the 389 million dollar
loan from the international monetary
fund for coronavirus relief in other
words he looks like a new winston
churchill doesn't he so
what is wrong with neb kelly why do we
say that he
like churchill is a controversial figure
well let's take a look at that now
[Music]
kelly's dark side on the surface
it looks like berkeley is doing a
fantastic job in the fight against
ukraine but if we look at the past we
see that this is not the first time the
homicide rate has dropped in el salvador
take a look at this graph
[Applause]
here you can see how in the year 2012
the number of homicides also dropped
dramatically
because the gangs had reached a truce
once the truce was over violence
increased again what's more if you look
closely you will see how homicides
peaked in 2015 but began to fall
before bucharest victory in other words
can we really say that bruckelli's iron
fist
is working with the data in hand it's
still too early to say what we can say
for sure is that raquel's firm hand is
much more than propaganda check this out
for kelly authorizes police to kill gang
members in el salvador after bloody
weekend el pais
but wait a minute because that's not all
another kelly strategies to end the
violence has been negotiation in
september 2020 the newspaper el faro
published this
investigative piece who kelly has been
negotiating with ms-13
a salvadorian gang for a reduction in
homicides and electoral support
ifarrow.net this newspaper has presented
leaked documents that show details of
this negotiation both sides have
negotiated privileges for gang members
in prison in exchange for reduction in
murders and support for bruckelli in the
upcoming elections
as you can imagine all of this classes
with berkeley's campaign promises that
he would never negotiate with criminals
and what happened to the newspaper that
investigated these negotiations what
happened to el faro
well they're already under investigation
by the government for possible
money laundering for kelly has also
publicly criticized media critical of
his government such as the associated
press
but i know what many of you are thinking
for the moment we are only talking about
minor issues brickell is neither the
first nor the last politician to
criticize media that criticizes him and
you are right what is starting to be of
concern is the following
[Music]
heavily armed police and soldiers enter
el salvador parliament
bbc and now i know what you're thinking
is this a coup d'etat in el salvador
well
no not really it was naya bukelli
himself who sent the army to the
parliament and why you may ask very
simple the government wanted to get a
loan of 109 million dollars approved in
order to modernize the police they
wanted to buy helicopters patrol cars
and surveillance equipment as popular as
bergelli brugelia's he does not have the
support of the parliament remember that
he won a presidential election but the
parliament was still dominated by the
two big traditional parties so berkeley
sent in the army to intimidate them into
approving the law
this occurred in february 2020 one year
later in february 2021 el salvador held
parliamentary elections and as you can
imagine the traditional parties were
practically
left outside with so much popular
support bruckelli has swept the floor
gave me an idea the legislative assembly
of el salvador has 84 deputies well
64 of them are buchelli's allies and
only 20 are from the opposition so what
has beekely done with so much power in
parliament check this out
el salvador's parliament sacks the
country's top judges the economist
and now i know a lot of you are thinking
in a country as corrupt as el salvador
it is normal that berkeley wants to
purge all the judges that were appointed
during the previous governments and you
are right but it is also true that this
way of doing politics is becoming more
and more authoritarian right now
berkeley has control of the executive
the legislature
and the judiciary so this is something
that we should condemn him for well
in some respects no no one can argue
that berkeley is extremely popular in
the country and
he has won elections but the
concentration of power is always bad
news
and that explains why the u.s is wary of
ending up supporting a would-be tyrant i
mean they've been burned before
check this out
us to pull el salvador funds on deep
concerns
over recent dismissals of top judges
reuters
so is this a good or a bad decision the
truth is that it's very hard to say on
the one hand it's clear that el salvador
needed a drastic change in his politics
it is difficult to end corruption in a
country if all the old elites are
against you on the other hand it would
not be the first
time that a messianic leader emerges in
latin america who ends up becoming a
tyrant so now the question is over to
you do you think it's a good thing the
united states or the european union put
pressure on naib bikeli to prevent him
from becoming a dictator or
maybe some heavy-handedness is needed
for a while so the country can put an
end to crime and corruption what are
your thoughts you can leave your answers
in the comments below as always don't
forget here on visualpolitik we release
new videos
every week so subscribe hit the little
bell button down there so you don't miss
any of our videos
if you like this video please give it a
like and i'll see you next time